FRED SAUER: All right.
Here's a developer who is a
little bit conscious about the
bill at the end of the day.
He says, each day, I fight
to really save every
penny on App Engine.
MANDY WAITE: Don't we all.
FRED SAUER: We all do.
How could you help us better
profile our applications?
App Stats, something you
actually mentioned, he thinks
is a little bit hard to use.
And what's the best way to
tune your application?
MANDY WAITE: An interesting
question.
OK, so we mentioned
App Stats earlier.
I think we've discussed
it before.
We think that App Stats is still
probably the way to go.
It's built into the platform
already, no
external tooling needed.
It's there, ready to go.
It will only profile
your RPCs.
It won't tell you where all of
the hotpots in your code are.
But it will definitely give you
a really good indication
about what your application is
spending its time doing,
particularly in terms of RPC
calls, calls to the data
store, that's includes,
as well.
It's very easy to get up
and running, as well.
So I'm not sure if it's
difficult for you to actually
get up and running and using it,
or if it's difficult for
you to actually get anything
meaningful from it.
But, generally, it's fairly
easy for both Java and for
Python to get up and running
with App Stats.
To get access to the console--
they provide a custom console
you can have access to, which
you can actually include in
your basic admin console.
Once you have that available
to you, you can
look at your RPCs.
You can look at each one of
your requests, open up the
request, and then drill down
into the request to see where
you're spending your time.
And even then, with Python--
I'm not sure this is available
with Java-- but with Python,
you can actually look
at the code that
generated the RPC call.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, in Python,
you have stack choices.
That's right.
MANDY WAITE: So with Python, you
can actually dive straight
in to where the code is that's
actually calling the wrong RPC
calls, and actually modify it
and redeploy the application
to see what result you get.
So that's really cool.
So I think we recommend
using App Stats,
definitely for RPCs.
I'm not really familiar
with any other
profiles for App Engine.
Although I did briefly
at [INAUDIBLE]
Academy actually produce a
profiler, Ben [? Cayman's ?]
made one.
Probably worth looking into.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, check out
Ben [? Cayman's ?] blog.
He does have a Python profiler
with some nice UI widgets that
tell you about the loading
performance of your site.
To kind of finish up on the App
Stats, I think what some
of our users sometimes run into
is they feel like all the
information that App Stats
provides is really
overwhelming.
And it's good maybe to
take a step back.
And one of things that App Stats
provides that I really
enjoy looking at is there's
these timeline graphs that
give you a breakdown of
the RPCs visually.
And 99% of the time when I'm
using App Stats, I only look
at the graphs.
There's a whole page [? throw ?]
of stack traces
and debugging information
and data that's being
sent back and forth.
Almost everything related
to performance of your
application, you can find just
by looking at the graph.
You can see whether you have
data store reads that are
staircased all sequentially
behind one another, or whether
they're happening in parallel.
You can see that you're making
a memcache call and then a
data store call, which
tells you there's a
memcache miss, right?
So really just getting
comfortable with those graphs,
I think, will provide most of
value with very little effort.
MANDY WAITE: Would you recommend
it for running on
production as well?
FRED SAUER: I do, but
depending on the
traffic of your site.
If you only have a few requests
per second, then
sure, run it.
If you're doing a lot of
traffic, what we recommend is
that you either deploy another
version in production that you
hit so you can say version dot
your app ID dot [? appsweb ?]
dot com and access
that directly.
And that way you don't have
all the data from all the
requests from all your users
piling on top of each other.
But you can very carefully just
poke at your application
and say, I'm going to do
this one request here.
And then I want to see the
App Stats profile.
We've even had people
with mobile clients.
They'll have a couple
users that
report performance problems.
And they'll change their
application to send down a
ping to those users and say, OK,
this mobile client should
connect to a different
back-end name.
And then those users are
isolated on their own version
where you can do diagnostics.
Maybe you can enable
some traces.
You can enable App Stats.
And then when everything's all
tuned, you tell the clients to
go back to the original
version.
So yeah, a lot of ways
to utilize it.